hopefully with a better internet
connection and last time I'm gonna do
this is going to be a quick stream again
but this is gonna be a hopefully
interactive we're gonna do some blitz
I'm wills five minutes let's do no
increment I'll accept maybe two to four
players will do random colors creates
and then hopefully people will join
already a few people joining accept
accept will do maybe let's do one more
player whoever joins next I'll accept
hello whatever your name is
thanks for watching and commenting okay
except okay it'll be a four-person Simon
will accept and will start I might as
well share the link case people don't
know I'm streaming a good luck everyone
I'll do multiple Simon's
it's hard to talk and type at the same
time if you get accepted into this one
okay start get some volume is it muted
what's going on I don't know why leach s
is not making any noise I'm not going oh
there it goes okay that was strange okay
four games at once time management is
going to be very important also
hopefully winning a quick game will make
things easier but we'll see what happens
it's two nights attack against caro-kann
Magnus dong interesting name let's play
e6 play my
one of my pet lines again so London will
take the night's hopefully he takes with
Queen let's play Queenie - tricky move
take take a six is usually not good
there so far I'm happy with most of
these openings this one is a typical
Grand Prix attack and I will try and
interact with the chat but it's gonna be
difficult playing four games and and
looking at the chat most of these games
I'm still in some sort of opening crap
play Bishop d6 he plays 97 wanting to
play Knight f6 let's play b3 there's a
bit of lag I'm not sure what's causing
it seems like my like whole operating
system is lagging strange hopefully I
can survive until the end of this imal
Isaac Lee what will happen to this
username when you get the GM title I'll
have to get a trademark on GM rosin and
then hopefully it's not a problem I do
own the domain name GM rosin calm so
anyone who's thinking implying that
fortune EU he won't be able to but that
will be a good problem to have and I
have to change my name to GM rosin okay
so I think I have some time advantage in
most of these games which is nice miss
Exeter No - nice attack for you I guess
that's true
she didn't allow me to play 903 in my
first few moves click Queen c7 there
this guy avoids the fork but loses upon
play Bishop c4 develop
Knight g4 aggressive f2 is attacked
let's play Bishop h4 that's a oh that's
a trade okay
hard to keep track here Bishop e3 my
team ended up winning the you 1,900
section congratulations max storm 59 not
bad next year you have to win the whole
tournament Oh
Bishop take f2 I don't think I'm losing
maybe there's some perpetual but looks
like a piece hopefully a free piece
hopefully not too much comp ok for games
still going I think I'm still relatively
happy with most of these games still up
on time the time scramble is going to be
difficult though if if it gets to that
point since play g6 it's got to keep
playing quick moves
this is probably the scariest position I
don't want to take on e6 and open that
file I could play Bishop g1 Queen up for
check let's start with night yeah let's
bring the knight to f3 take that pawn
rook f7 yeah this game is gonna be the
hopefully the first to finish if I can
get some attack maybe not if we trade
Queens ok we'll trade Queens better end
game for black or for whites
um scheme I want to attack but it's
difficult but I have to move let's play
this that should probably defend the
beat on display before bring the Commun
down on time in this game which is not
good
I bring the King in more I got three a5
just have to keep moving quickly oh I
didn't see that move that was a good
move White's not getting made it but
it's very scary I might lose that game
though ok we'll trade bishops no we
won't trade bishops might still alive
black one back some material let's
defend open Kyle his rook on a it is
tied down so that's a good thing
sleeve - Beth hates G for Miss Exeter
will probably flag unfortunately for her
let's play g4 or pawn storm take that
down the exchange oops
know how I got down in exchange
let's defend that was a good move
let's do this Matt hopefully I'm not
getting mated there uh I could take this
is a that's a free piece looks like this
is scary he's writing made in one I have
to play out five please don't make me 94
take the bishop so backs up a bishop
there miss Exeter was like disconnected
maybe I don't know if you were it helps
me let's defend that pawn so my king has
some escape via g5 still have to manage
my time here
Oh from here but not twitch that's
strange
that's a free pawn and a free exchange
do I want to take with team I could take
with pawn I think there's some annoying
checks but I have worked G for in the
very end it's bring the knight to more
aggressive square it's my vision t4 okay
rook trade oh he winds up on should
still be a little bit better for white
lacy for King g6 more active King yeah
this is difficult it's to take the pawn
bring the knight back somewhere that was
a good move man it's time scramble stuff
okay so I have to flag this guy I know
what happened here I thought I wanted
peace let's do that trade
[Music]
threatening mate good move
let's do this yeah this is not good
let's do that
take the Knights think the King back do
that I'm gonna lose at least a few of
these games I think unless I flag people
can't fork the rook and pawn let's take
that no I want to yeah let's take a Tris
tacky enough to you can take it's hard
to flag people playing multiple games at
once but I'm trying my best
I'll take that pawn do this and hope he
still meets me it's to that injury to
meet him let's do this it's almost mate
let's take the bishop first I still
haven't lost a game which is good I have
to okay that's made in - that's good I'm
trying I'm really trying
don't meet me know do I really win three
games somehow I won three games nice job
chess for newbies mating me with two
seconds left
that's close
what happened in those games this guy
just for Oh miss Exeter resigned or
flagged one of the two how do I win this
game black resigned well that was
helpful because it would have been hard
to time scramble in four games what
happened in that other game and this
game black either flagged or his mind
this was actually an interesting endgame
I think white should just be winning the
problem for black is it's hard to like
but has no time to win the b-pawn and
then after rook yeah the book it's kind
of stuck defending itself on the best
try here is to play rook rookie to but
the problem actually let's say rookie to
came here uh let's say check came here
check I have King f5 because I'm ready
to build the bridge with rook f4 so that
would have been interesting
maybe rope
rook f2 I'm trying to figure out how
light winds this I guess now I could
play some move like rook rook g4 yeah it
should be I don't like rook hearing
right there and then the one game I lost
what happened
yeah the scheme I don't know if this is
a sound sacrifice but it was probably a
good practical decision so it wasn't
easy nine of three terrible to have
completely missing this should take c4
hello axe villager good to see you too
so I could have yeah I probably could
have taken on e6 but it's dangerous it's
already very dangerous rook d8 was a
good move um I would guess the computer
says blacks just completely winning yeah
no hope slacks pieces are just so strong
against whites pieces okay because
there's lag and because um it's
difficult to play four games at once I'm
gonna play three games in the next imal
has a stream been up for long already
I've been streaming for like the last 15
minutes so not too long so back to Simon
how do I create a new one so I will post
a new Simon so I'm only accepting three
players if you want to join you can do
so by going to the simultaneous mm
players do random color - so how this
will work I'll share the link in the
chat and then in a few moments I'll pick
just three random candidates so there's
no guarantee that that you'll be picked
actually the leech s random algorithm
will will determine the candidates so
this guy saying pick me you'll probably
have like
what are the odds if I pick three I'll
wait for there to be 20 players so a 3
out of 20 chance longer time control
maybe I would do a longer time control
but I have to leave in about like 40
minutes so I could do a time control
with increment I don't I could go on for
a long time
okay all right be the odds okay except
Oliver Hansen Congrats X I sparks
okay these are relatively low rate of
players so I'll do one more I'll do four
again even though I didn't want to do
for just for newbies just played and he
just beat me so I'm sorry but you're not
playing again I'll do another guy okay I
don't know who was accepted maybe ill
Helicon so these are the four and we'll
start a stream you did what okay I have
no time to focus on the chat this time
I'm going to try and win all the games
we'll see how it goes as white I'll play
London because black I guess I'm playing
against the London
C 5 C for London again so 3 London's 3
London's in 1 Budapest h3 not a great
move there I'm gonna try and play
quicker than last time these people
Fleming Bishop at 5 so early
like Queenie 7 tricky move hoping for g3
Queen b3 okay we'll take this guy's
saying not a lot of time for me that's
the nature of what Simon's it's never
going to be enough time
but I'll try my best calling will ignore
that for the time being let's play Queen
before check I'm so quiet the game get
turned down okay I should be louder now
the gain on my mic was almost muted so
let's probably buy let me know if it's
better better great okay
back I just hung a night life is good
the ship a3 almost traps the rook it
might be forced to b7 hangs so many free
gifts take their look c1 this is gonna
mess up the UH probably the recording
for YouTube if I've changed the mic
midstream
but whatever someone's asking if there's
another sigh mole yeah there will
probably be at least one more sign after
this so feel free to hang around
I could also host like a tournament no
well we'll do it one more sign well
after this most likely if this one
doesn't kill me Queen d7 usually not a
good move because it runs into 95 free
pawn somewhere the free pawn there okay
someone just cheered 100 hundred bits
Thank You rainbows guy so generous um I
want to punish this guy 95 Bishop taking
five so I could take first I don't want
to think too long let's do that and
thanks for the follow russet gold potato
appreciate it um Queen a thought check
why not
free pawn 95 I don't think I can punish
this guy will have to play positionally
bring the Queen to some more useful
square this is not what I wanted like
all these games are positional somehow I
want a game already I don't know which
game i won
but that's nice I want to trade probably
when c6 will be weak let's take the
bishop put the 911 C 5 so up a knight in
that position the ship T 7 may have
blundered the b-pawn but maybe not I
don't know put me in exile or I unfollow
JK JK
so I maybe I'll have to do some
incentive for uh to think about this uh
man this guy just chopped off the head
of my triple pawns um
that's fine okay we'll take there okay
new rule just kind of out of the blue if
you want to guarantee yourself to get
accepted in a Simon Singh on Twitch and
then I'll pick you regardless of
regardless of anything I'll just pick
you because I have very few subscribers
will take that night I think I just won
the exchange in that candle so now I
just have to manage my time okay they're
so black Oh black Supper rook that's
nice
someone else has followed never been
timid thank you
set up a cheapo bring the Queen back to
g6 I guess do that so I was better
earlier in this game but now I'm not
sure age six he's not falling for it if
I can get both rooks to the seventh life
will be good I just have to knock it
back rank needed okay that came
completely winning yet people are not
caring about their pieces thanks for the
follow a cool Ian cool name Knights kind
of stuck here knight c6 is a bit
adventurous but let's play it
what's Castle King safety first
so I've won two games that's good and I
have Queen a one check even better this
guy's probably winning a three that's
throwing f30 oh my god
play bishop he can castle too right I
forgot if he's moved his King Bishop
yeah we'll still play Bishop a4 ooh okay
97 let's take this bishop first this
game is going to be interesting because
my rooks are active but he's winning a
pawn or two I think
but okay I think I have things under
control this game completely winning up
working a bishop the other game is
probably the most interesting what to do
he's attacking me I could just take yeah
let's just take yeah this is actually
really interesting I'm not sure whether
to play King f2 or rook c7 here it's
flaking off too so you can't really stop
rook c7 next like to bring my queen back
but it's tied down to the bishop so I
play Queen a4 I actually don't know what
to do here every move his winning let's
just take the fun
King g3 we got seven so some sort of
time scramble happening let's play h4 he
may have wanted to play H for himself
let's do this okay he's winning the
bishop
let's bring my queen back good move for
G eights
but also passive let's try and make this
guy ASAP they work a six white should
win at least upon their raka for the
brooklet should be killer
it's to Brooke e7
that's a check oh I'm losing on time but
that's made in one that's nice
almost flag that game good try whoever
that was okay well do one more sign wall
that went well
I want all the games uh I guess someone
just resigned I guess after I won the b7
pawn back I resigned
this game was the closest I had like ten
seconds in the end but that's why in
like these double work endings the rook
activity and the coordination between
the rooks can be worth they can be worth
at least upon sometimes more than a pawn
I think I was playing for a win here and
already it's difficult
he shouldn't probably shouldn't play e5
but I'm entirely sure what else to do
maybe rook I don't know maybe g5
activate this rook because he if he
opens the G file he could win g2 and my
team could be a target so but I don't
know what's going on here because I'm
almost meeting his team I take on
threatening made in one he takes I take
and if he takes here I made him first so
we've got have an interesting and game
like both players trying to mate each
other quicker but anyway we'll do one
more cycle last one and then I have to
go so let me go create a new one again
it will be five minutes I'll probably do
four players again like how to manage my
time
and it will still be five minutes
no increments around colors creates
anyone who's watching on twitch I'll
share the link in the chat Oh people
joining already okay
so we'll wait for like 20 people to join
and then we'll do like random random
candidates so the odds maybe aren't that
great but I'll try not to accept the
same people twice so we'll see 15 in
about 30 seconds yeah I'm popular okay
we are accepting people there's only 16
so far I said I would wait till 20 you
should pick some me chess donors how do
I know if someone's elite chest donor is
it this is it that symbol yeah next time
like I'll do streams like this again
next time I'll have a more systematic
way of taking people but I do like the
randomness like that way everyone gets a
fair chance but yeah it's probably a
good idea to reward leech s donors or
subscribers either one okay except it's
one two three four
ooh a cool ian is 2315 everyone else's
like under thirteen hundred and a B and
Eric got accepted I know he was
frustrated in the chat but hopefully now
he's not frustrated okay we're accepting
or we're uh we're starting this is gonna
be difficult with a strong player but
hopefully I can knock out some other
players quickly
so good luck everyone Thank You Isaac
Lee for the cheer even if it's one bit
okay we're starting um I have to watch
out for a cool Ian okay it will play
normal openings it's lagging a little
bit but should be okay
actually it might not be okay oh it's
lagging too much the goal is to win one
game or multiple games quickly yeah it's
definitely lagging that's unfortunate
pay to play $100 interesting $100 is
probably too much to pay I figured
rewarded with something a lot more okay
time management is not very good as
people want to flag me but I'm trying my
best
play h5 know this is a cool Ian I didn't
mean to be unsound against a cool Ian
but oh he didn't take it that's good
let's do that I'll take do this this is
difficult I feel like people in the
Simon are playing better than people in
the last level b3 I guess I think I'm
down on time in every game which is not
pleasant but I just have to keep playing
quickly I guess that guy couldn't win
when the d4 pawn if he wants to
oh he saw it's okay C seven will take
there did I just oh my gosh okay I
resigned that was terrible I'll try and
win these other three games I guess I
didn't see the line on b5 it's hard to
like have a good player thrown into the
mix of like a bunch of lower rated
players then I have to costume
constantly look like at the the username
take them more seriously
okay these other games hopefully I can
manage to win but nice job of cooling in
four completely punishing me that guy
didn't want me to to meet him on each -
thank you for the support contra chess
Bishop f5 is a mood I guess queen bee I
was expecting Queen a slightly sneakier
let's get the half-open file up a piece
in this game okay this game should be
over somehow
but where's a mate okay I have a cool
idea I don't know if it works I probably
doesn't work okay let's play Queen c5
get the Knight to f5 do this
miss Exeter bringing up the time that I
lost to her I think I remember that but
I've tried to suppress it from my memory
but it probably did happen
okay so this should be manageable it's
to that this guy wants to meet me on g2
sneaky sneaky it's not too many ways to
the Fed plane 92 Laight 94 let's play 94
book three three three three is asking
if I'm accepting new students I am
except like the last week I've been
getting messages I've been getting
several messages every day so for some
reason the demand for coaching has gone
way up but if you are interested in
taking lessons you can go to Lee chest
org slash coach and you can find my
coaching profile and send me a message
and all the information is there
including rates and my teaching
philosophy and this guy just fine mate
thank you very much so one more game
King f7 was played so the only danger is
this made on g2 thank thank you culture
chess for the follow by the way I'm
gonna play Brooke g3 safety and
aggression I'm sorry it's a what's that
guy's name a B and Eric wasn't your game
it's play Knight g5
okay what to do
Bishop c7 is a nice little move
obstructing the Queen and that was the
whole point
mr. nathen e7 okay that was nice I
really messed up that one game just
hanging everything on who books thank
you for the follow this might be painful
to look at but let's see what happens
playing someone see her either than me
almost as high rated is me a strange
opening with Bishop d3 but it's playable
maybe I should play d6 sooner than e 5
and question miss Bishop yeah this was
the first moment like I thought I was
playing someone much weaker so I
wouldn't be too worried about sacking
the night but I think he can go ahead
and take here cuz I'm not really
threatening each to and then I'm just
plain that you won and there shouldn't
be enough confer for black but I don't
know what happened the game ok White's
position was probably okay until I
played my t4 yeah 94 is just a bad move
cuz he wins at least a pawn queen c6 was
bad because he takes it or he plays
Bishop b4 and then takes it I lost a
tempo and I hung my queen that was
really bad I'm banning someone who's
spamming the chat I might need a few
more mods
um but for now okay I might just have to
prohibit links in the chat I don't know
yeah Queen c7 such a bad move I sure the
flick Queen see it but then White's
still much better I should take to you
for like zapathon has better pieces
that's unfortunate
okay well thanks everyone for watching
and playing me uh wasn't the easiest
doing these boots novels they are
quicker than these standard cycles which
helps keep up the pace
cool Ian it was interesting but I wanted
to try out that opening yeah not a bad
opening at least to confuse me Anna
Simon
okay I'm going to end it now this is
very quick this is like 40 minutes but
I'll be back in the future um feel free
like if you want to see anything
specific if you want more samples if you
wanna like if you want to see me play
classical chest and your commentary if
you want me if you want to see me do
puzzles let me know what you want to see
and I will be back in the future bye
guys